HEY, MATT, I THINK THERE MIGHT
BE ONE MORE GIFT FOR YOUR MOM,
RIGHT THERE.
>> IT HASN'T BEEN A NORMAL YEAR,
SO THIS CHRISTMAS, GET HER
SOMETHING EXTRAORDINARY DURING
THE LEXUS DECEMBER TO REMEMBER
SALES EVENT.
>> NATHAN, YOU DIDN'T.
>> WITH FLEXIBLE FINANCING AND
ZERO PERCENT APR, THERE'S NEVER
BEEN A BETTER TIME TO BUY OR
LEASE A NEW LEXUS.
>> MERRY CHRISTMAS, BABY.
>> ARE YOU [ BLEEP ] KIDDING ME
NATHAN?
DID YOU SERIOUSLY BUY A CAR
WITHOUT ASKING ME?
>> WELL, 'CAUSE FOR CHRISTMAS.
>> THIS IS A MAJOR PURCHASE.
>> RIGHT.
BUT IT WAS A DECEMBER TO
REMEMBER, SO.
>> IT'S A LEXUS.
WE DON'T HAVE THE MONEY FOR
THIS, NATHAN.
>> WE DON'T?
>> NO, WE DON'T.
YOUR FATHER DOESN'T --
YOUR FATHER HASN'T WORKED SINCE
LAST MARCH.
>> WHAT?
>> YEAH, COVID HAS HIT A LOT OF
PEOPLE HARD, AND I'M NO
EXCEPTION.
>> NATHAN, YOU GOT FIRED IN
MARCH, 2019.
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
>> HEY, PAL, I GUESS YOUR OLD
MAN'S BUSTED.
>> IT'S BEGINNING TO LOOK A LOT
LIKE SAVINGS, SO GET TO YOUR
LOCAL LEXUS DEALER TODAY.
>> HOW MUCH DID YOU SPEND ON
THIS RIDICULOUS CAR, NATHAN.
>> ONLY $3,999 DUE AT SIGNING.
FOUR GRAND.
IT'S NOT THAT MUCH, BABE.
>> AND HOW MUCH IS THE MONTHLY
PAYMENT?
>> THE WHAT?
>> DO YOU THINK THIS ENTIRE CAR
COSTS $4,000?
>> UH-HUH.
>> THERE'S A MONTHLY PAYMENT!
>> YEAH, BUT WITH A WITH ZERO
PERCENT APER, I THINK IT'S ALL
GOOD.
>> APER, DO YOU MEAN APR?
>> I'M PRETTY SURE IT'S APER.
>> WOW.
JUST, WOW.
HEY, COME ON, IT'S CHRISTMAS.
THIS IS GOOD.
I DID A GOOD THING FOR US, LET'S
ENJOY IT.
>> DAD, IT'S 9:00 IN THE
MORNING.
>> SO, IT'S NOT LIKE I HAVE WORK
LATER.
>> COME ON.
>> HEY!
>> HEY, NEIGHBOR.
>> YOU BOUGHT A LEXUS?
YOU COME TO ME THREE WEEKS AGO,
"OH, MIKE, HELP ME, I NEED
MONEY, I CAN'T BUY CHRISTMAS
GIFTS FOR MY FAMILY.
MY WIFE DOESN'T RESPECT ME."
>> I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> "MY WIFE'S CHEATING ON ME."
WITH EVERYONE
>> MOM, YOU ARE?
>> "I WANT TO LOOK COOL IN FRONT
OF MY SON'S GIRLFRIEND."
>> EW, DAD.
IS THAT WHY YOU PIERCED YOUR
EAR?
>> NO, I'VE HAD THIS FOREVER.
>> "I JUST NEED FIVE GRAND TO
GET BACK ON MY FEET," AND THEN
YOU BUY A LEXUS.
>> YEAH, WELL IT WAS BEGINNING
TO LOOK A LOT LIKE SAVINGS AT MY
LOCAL LEXUS DEALER,
>> I WANT MY MONEY BACK, MAN.
TOMORROW.
>> HEY, KATHY.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, WE'RE TAKING
THIS CAR BACK TO THE DEALERSHIP,
NOW.
>> OKAY, GRINCH, LET'S GO.
>> I BETTER DRIVE.
>> MAYBE WE STOP BY JENNA'S ON
THE WAY OVER AND SHOW HER THIS
COOL CAR YOUR DAD GOT, HUH.
>> SHUT UP!
>> GIVE THE GIFT OF LEXUS AN